on this channel i'm always talking about
combining multiple different forms of
training because i genuinely believe
that that's the best way to get the most
comprehensive fitness and performance
profile i don't think that any one
modality can offer everything you need
to perform your very best one of the
criticisms i sometimes get about this
though is that it's a bit overwhelming
where do you even begin when you have
such a smorgasbord to choose from
kettlebell training bodybuilding
powerlifting calisthenics mobility
long distance running martial arts etc
well a great place to start for a lot of
people would be to take two different
forms of training and to combine them
and as it happens there are many great
pairings that go together like great
cheeses and wines where they perfectly
complement each other make up for what's
missing and compound on those benefits a
while back i made a video called
functional aesthetics where i talked
about how beneficial it could be to
combine functional training you know
traditional functional type movements
with bodybuilding training this way the
functional athletes would get some of
the isolated hypertrophy that's missing
from that kind of training they could
work on the smaller muscle groups that
even functional training might overlook
conversely the bodybuilder would get
some additional aesthetics as well from
things like the obliques that aren't
traditionally hit by bodybuilding
routines at the same time they learn to
combine those different areas of
strength into more compound movements
and complex movement patterns they build
stability balance and all that good
stuff check out that video if you're
interested today i'm talking about
another pairing that's perhaps even more
powerful that's to combine calisthenics
with athletic training
so just to reiterate i'm not saying by
any means this is the very best form of
training this is what i'm going to be
doing from now on this is just one
possible combination of many that
demonstrates how pairing different
workouts different forms of training can
be an excellent approach and these two
really do go together like starsky and
hutch
so what i'm talking about here well
calisthenics of course means body weight
training i'm talking about push-ups air
squats sit-ups etc pull-ups however past
a certain point a true calisthenics
athlete needs to move on to more complex
movements more challenging movements
they're going to be doing things like
hands-down push-ups planche progressions
front levers that kind of thing
meanwhile by athletic training i'm
talking about the kinds of things that a
coach might give to an athlete if they
wanted to improve their performance in
sports so we're talking about things
like hip thrusts bounds sprinting drills
we're talking about depth jumps and box
jumps perhaps some knees over toes stuff
like a deep atg split squat we're
talking various cable exercises
rotational movements that kind of thing
banded lateral walks bounds
anterior reaches that kind of stuff and
there's loads of reasons why these
things go together like sonic and tails
the one thing that both these types of
training have in common is they don't
pack on too much weight too much mass an
athlete doesn't want to be extremely
bulky for the majority of activities
because otherwise it's going to slow
them down it's going to get in the way
and whilst you can be powerful and
explosive and have a lot of muscle on
the whole this kind of training is going
to lead to slower performance if nothing
else it's going to land you in a higher
weight class which can be detrimental
for many different sports of course your
calisthenics athletes don't want to pack
on too much weight because it's much
harder to do a full planche or a
one-armed pull-up if you weigh more so
in both scenarios we want a high
strength to weight ratio this is
something they have in common however
one thing that's missing often from
calisthenics training that athletics can
offer is leg training
now before you come at me and tell me
that there's lots of great leg exercises
in calisthenics of course you have
things like pistol squats [ __ ] squats
air squats squat jumps lunges etc the
truth is that in order to really build
mass on your legs it's often a lot
easier to add extra weight and you can
build some decent legs but this isn't
something that calisthenics is known for
let's put it that way and at the same
time legs in particular if you want to
do things like planche getting them too
big and bulky really can be detrimental
to your performance so you do tend to
see that calisthenics athletes sometimes
have slightly smaller legs in comparison
to their upper body however this is
where athletic training can fit like a
glove because this is going to come in
and give you a way to train your legs
that isn't focused on building massive
bulk but gives you even more balance
even more stability explosiveness
running speed you're going to add power
and strength to the legs but not in the
way it's going to lead to massive
thunder thighs or going to make you
really heavy or going to negatively
impact on your mobility
at the same time this kind of training
often uses body weight or just a little
bit of extra weight often about 30
percent of body weight which is optimal
for increasing explosiveness across many
different exercises and studies
this is a perfect way to train legs as a
calisthenics athlete that's going to
give you this whole extra dimension to
your performance because now you're also
running super fast and jumping super
high and darting and cutting and
changing direction on top of being able
to do things like one arm pull-ups and
plants you're just going to be this
athletic performance machine and adding
athletic training to your calisthenics
routine is also a great way to get some
cardio in or some high-intensity
interval training because once again you
can just simply combine steady-state
cardio with calisthenics or you can just
perform high-high repetition push-ups in
a fashion that makes it more like a form
of cardio but i think doing these
high-intensity interval training you
know sprints and drags and med ball
slams in the fashion that you would do
for athletic training is a really good
option too
and in a similar manner something else
that's often missing from calisthenics
training is rotational strength i've
talked on this channel before about how
important rotational strength and power
can be and this isn't just calisthenics
it's missing from so much training
whether it's power lifting whether it's
bodybuilding we so rarely twist our
bodies in training even though it's
something we do all the time in real
life and in sports whether you're
wrestling someone whether you're pushing
or pulling pretty much anything and even
just walking irritate your body when
you're throwing training the serape
effect building powerful hips and a
rotational core this is all absolutely
crucial i think to over performance and
it's the perfect example of why picking
just one form of training often isn't
enough i like to do kick throughs but
there's not a ton of option you can do
with calisthenics training however if
you look at the average athletics
training program it often does include
lots of stuff for rotation and not just
anti-rotation like you might get from
calisthenics from things like one-armed
push-ups etc but actually rotating and
twisting the body against resistance
whether it's something like a cable wood
chop or even something like a rotational
med ball slam once again you're plugging
a gap that's missing from calisthenics
with something really cool from
athletics
so now you might be thinking you can get
lots of benefits as a calisthenics
athlete by adding athletic style
training but what benefit does the
athletic trainee get from adding
calisthenics
well first of all calisthenics is
fantastic for building an extremely
strong core this is something that
already exists in sports training and
athletics however if you use
calisthenics you're going to build it to
a whole extra level as stuart mcgill
says it's really important to have a
powerful core because this allows you to
express force and power through your
limbs
i always use the analogy of hitting
someone with a floppy stick with a nail
on the end versus hitting someone with a
hard plank of wood with a nail on the
end you're going to transform more power
via the hard plank of wood because it's
not leaking energy
and then calisthenics are doing all
these moves that require an incredibly
powerful and stable core this is one of
the reasons why gymnastics is often
thought of as one of the activities that
has the most transfer to all the other
forms of sport and athletics so this
would just be a way for an athlete or
someone who's interested in sports to
take their performance potentially to
the next level at the same time
athletics training on its own doesn't
necessarily offer a lot of hypertrophy
and muscle building in a more isolated
and traditional sense you're not just
bulking up specific muscle groups
because there's not enough isolation in
there
whilst you might do squats and deadlifts
the aim here is not hypertrophy at the
same time you're not going to be doing
lots and lots of curls most likely
however calisthenics is excellent for
building muscle whilst you might not
pack on the bulk that you might get from
bodybuilding or powerlifting
calisthenics can build some of the very
best physiques going not only because of
that really powerful core but because of
the intense work you do on the shoulders
and the lats and because of the fact
that you're working with your own body
weight which leads to a really ripped
and lean physique
and the other big way in which athletic
training can benefit from adding some
calisthenics is simply by creating a
much more well-rounded athlete because
athletic training often means training
for a particular sport or event and
sometimes this can mean not getting the
full package becoming too specialist in
any one area can be a recipe for
imbalances and injuries and it can lead
to problems down the road even if you're
using a more broad athletic style
training without necessarily having a
particular sport in mind you might not
be doing things like training the biceps
in a big way or the triceps or the
shoulders or even the lats because you
might rarely be hanging so by adding
calisthenics you get this far more
well-rounded physique that plugs all of
those gaps once again and at the same
time isn't going to add lots of bulk and
isn't going to slow you down because
you're using your own body weight both
these styles of training are about
becoming an absolute master of your body
weight it's just that calisthenics is
about defying gravity and controlling
movement in space whereas athletic
training is about being explosive fast
and nimble and by combining these two
things you can create a truly powerful
and well-rounded athlete and then once
you've done that you can start looking
at adding a little bit of kettlebell
training bodybuilding etc as well to
become even more rounded still just to
be absolutely clear it's not like you
can't get almost all of these benefits
from doing a purely calisthenics-based
workout or from doing a purely
athletics-based workout there are plenty
of exercises for the legs if you're
doing calisthenics like i've said it's
more just that this gives you a bigger
pool to select from and where there
might be a slightly more limited
selection in calisthenics you get a
wider selection in athletics and in many
cases the other way around and that's
why these two
mesh together so nicely
if you're looking for a program that
combines multiple different styles of
training that includes things from
athletic training from calisthenics then
of course you can try my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system and that also comes with over two
hours of instructional training videos
that also incorporates things like
kettlebell training mobility work brain
training all in a systematic fashion
that's adaptable to any ability level
and nearly any kind of equipment so i'll
put the link to that in the description
down below if you're interested either
way thank you so much for watching this
one guys i massively appreciate it let
me know in the comments down below do
you think that this kind of athletic
training plus calisthenics is a good mix
another big one for me is powerlifting
with kettlebell training and i might
talk about that in a future video if
this is something that people find
interesting subscribe if you want to see
more like this hit the bell button for
notifications and like and share around
if you want to that helps me out
massively and thank you so much for
watching this one guys
bye for now